there are those that it's not a function
of age and it probably isn't even a
function entirely of education or
political leanings but there's a there's
a temper in probably America but for
sure I know in America and maybe
worldwide for the literal a literal take
on everything that that reality TV has
taken advantage of and incorporated as
part of itself and the that the literal
take on things is a take without irony
and without edge and without it's
usually a fairly a certitude to it why
don't you write a book that has nothing
to do with war is if that's a certain
possibility you should certainly try to
do it as a way of recovering from the
war and you want to say a number of
things this is not just a book about war
you idiot and it's a book about love and
a book about storytelling but you also
feel overwhelmed by by the knowledge
that you're not going to get through
that's a liberal-minded are going to
remain literal-minded and maybe someone
else can help them but someone else is
not there's not this guy so there's a
there's a wave of anger or bitterness it
has to do with Vietnam has to do with a
kind of mindset of literal all around me
that doesn't fit my take on the world
it's in my experience in the world where
it's hard for me to take anything very
literally boards I love you there as
soon as they're uttered I'm suspect how
much and when will you stop and will you
in what way do love me and what is love
to you by the way is that forever or is
it till the next you know person passage
or all this stuff complicates whereas
someone else's that will love is love
and if you don't know what it is you're
really you're poor guy and
they're fake
probably is too probably
Stewart parody it make fun of it
ridicule it and put it in this place
partly I'm I'm sympathetic to the
literal that is I'm sympathetic with
some mom is holding a dead kid in their
arms and how else are she to take it but
here's my dead child and so there's a
part of me that understands it and is
sympathetic to it and probably the
better part of me is that way where I
have at least at least some capacity to
as English novelist kind of have to have
to imagine other Ness outside oneself
and as a consequence my books are filled
with characters who bear no resemblance
to me and and who can be villainous in
ways I'm not villainous and can be good
in ways I'm not good that I think the
capacity for for empathy or
understanding goes with the successful
book because you have to create others
characters and other angles of vision on
material for the booked of ring-ring
with some kind of authenticity
among my fellow soldiers in Vietnam I
mean there was and remains to this day
could have absence of that kind of
empathy a dead child is a dead gook and
a good Vietnamese woman or one of their
legs blown off as a woman gook with her
legs blown off and it pretty much
remains that way to these days 40 years
later these same buddies I served with
in Vietnam don't have much empathy for
the so-called enemy and I doubt they
would be capable of because because
that's their view no writing because
things they carried they'd write another
book it would be a it would be a much
different book